est-ce qu'elle prend la feuille pour
sécher ses larmes ce serait un peu
étrange qu'elle prenne un mouchoir Mira
nous faisons des livres pour enfants
c'est peut-être mieux de les préparer la
vie va inévitablement briser leurs rêves
et leurs espoirs
[Musique]
que tu n'es plus là je ne peux toujours
pas y croire
les yeux en espérant te voir à nouveau
je dois avoir le numéro de son copain
décédé c'est super
je trouve que c'est touchant il y a
personne qui
te reproduit
arrête tu me dis ça comme si ça faisait
des siècles disons que ça devrait pas de
mal de t'y remettre
qu'on pourrait prendre notre temps
[Musique]
tu te rappelles ma robe jaune je la
mettrai pour aller à l'opération je vais
aller la voir c'est une parfaite
inconnue qui t'écrit j'ai besoin de
mettre un visage sur ses textos
[Musique]
c'est de sa fille je crois pas non oh
c'est dingue quelqu'un vient de te
donner rendez-vous alors sienne
elle me trouve intéressante il faut que
tu lui dises la vérité tu aurais dû la
prévenir tout de suite
je lui dis elle ne parlera plus jamais
j'avais hâte d'être à ce soir j'ai
l'impression qu'on se connaissait je
sais pas tu crois qu'on peut tomber
amoureux de quelqu'un uniquement par ces
mots je te trouve très mignon
plus je la découvre plus elle me plaît
[Musique]
ce genre de chose ne se produit pas
juste comme ça l'amour a un plan pour
chacun d'entre nous
[Musique]
bonjour c'est Céline Dion oui bien sûr
et moi je suis Mariah Carey
et oui c'est vrai moi c'est pas vrai
bonjour